à une centaine de kilomètres à l'est de
kiev dans un de ces villages récemment
libéré les troupes russes bel et bien
partie c'est une autre angoisse qui
s'est installé parmi les habitants
bonjour messieurs vous pouvez venir voir
chez moi il y a un trou dans mon mur
peut-être qu'il y un explosif à
l'intérieur
on viendra plus tard
merci merci beaucoup cette équipe de
démineurs l'ukrainien une autre mission
ce matin ils sont sollicités sans cesse
des missiles des mines rien que dans les
deux villages alentours il y au moins
dix mille engins explosifs
ils se rendent sur ce champ de blé à la
sortie du village là où un avion de
chasse ukrainien a été abattu il ya un
mois environ
c'est une partie d'un missile liesse il
ya des charges explosives très
dangereuse à l'intérieur
il faut absolument le détruire sans quoi
cette aire ne pourra pas être cultivée
l'équipe de démineurs pose une petite
requête à côté du missile dangereux puis
installent un dispositif pour déclenché
l'explosif à distance
on va se mettre là bas à une
cinquantaine de mètres protégés par
leurs camions
les combats ont laissé derrière eux des
milliers d'engins non explosés
attends moi j'arrive les troupes russes
ont également souvent poser des pièges
avant de partir
dans le jardin de cette maison privée on
a trouvé un engin explosif il était
dissimulé dans une batterie externe
pauvres - le jardin de cette maison a
été occupé pendant 20 jours montre
l'engin est rapidement neutralisée par
les démineurs mais la propriétaire est
toujours terrorisé il ya bouillouses
mais j'ai peur de sortir à cause de ça
méconnaître s'enfermer j'ai toujours
peur je ne sors pas de chez moi
comment vivre entouré d'engins explosifs
de toutes sortes et de toutes tailles
c'est la récolte 2022 chez les voisins
c'est un missile ultra puissant qui
s'est enfoncé dans la terre sans
exploser
à l'intérieur il ya 700 kg d'explosifs
le même type de missile a été utilisé à
marioupol il a tué 160 personnes
s'il explose est il n'y aurait plus rien
autour
le gouvernement ukrainien estime que la
zone a inspecté éventuellement à déminer
représente pas moins de 300 mille
kilomètres carrés la moitié de la
superficie de la france un travail
colossal